the rel do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a Song of Ice and Fire
video today I want to break down another
one of my favorite chapters from the
books the main reason why I decided to
do this chapter is because it was
completely left out of the television
show Game of Thrones this is another
scene I wish they would have included
because Brian Stark is arguably one of
the most important characters in the
story and one day he may even become the
most powerful well we get a glimpse of
this at the very beginning of the story
when he is visited by the three-eyed
crow when he still in a coma we never
get the chance to see this on the TV
show and that's unfortunate because what
brain is able to see during his coma is
fascinating he doesn't just see things
that are happening presently but he also
gets the glimpse of the future and most
importantly the three-eyed crow takes
him beyond the wall to the heart of
winter Brian has no idea how important
he actually is but bloodraven does this
in an attempt to open up brains third
eye so he can become a green seer he
needs to know that Westeros will soon
face a threat that could potentially
wipe out all of humanity what's
interesting is the Starks have been
warning people about this threat the
entire time and they didn't even know it
I'll explain that later but for now
let's take a look at what happens to
bran when he's in a coma
after he had been pushed from the window
by Jaime Lannister this is actually a
very short chapter much shorter than any
of the other ones I've previously read
on the channel but that doesn't stop
this chapter from being packed full of
information hopefully you will follow
along with me as I read then I will
break down each thing brain seas shall
we begin it seemed as though he had been
falling for years fly a voice whispered
in the darkness but brain did not know
how to fly so all he could do was fall
maester Luwin made a little boy of clay
baked him till he was hard and brittle
dressed him in brands clothes and flung
him off a roof bran remembered the way
he shattered but I never fall he said
falling the ground was so far below him
he could barely make it out through the
gray mists that world around him but he
could feel how fast he was falling and
he knew what was waiting for him down
there even in the dreams you could not
fall forever he would wake up in the
instant before he hit the ground he knew
you always woke up in the instant before
you hit the ground and if you don't the
voice asked the ground was closer now
still far far away a thousand miles away
but closer than it had been
it was cold here in the darkness there
was no Sun no stars only the ground
below coming up the smash him in the
gray mists in the whispering voice he
wanted to cry not cry fly I can't fly
brand said I can't I can't
how do you know have you ever tried the
voice was high in thin brain looked
around to see where it was coming from a
crow was spiraling down with him just
out of reach following him as he fell
help me
he said I'm trying the crow replied say
got any corn bran reached into his
pocket as the darkness spun dizzily
around him when he pulled his hand out
golden kernels slid from between his
fingers into the air they fell with him
the crow landed on his hand and began to
eat are you really a crow bran asked are
you really falling the crow asked aback
it's just a dream bran said is it as to
the crow I'll wake up when I hit the
ground bran told the bird you'll die
when you hit the ground
the crows said it went back to eating
corn bran looked down he could see the
mountains now their peaks white was snow
and the silver thread of rivers and dark
woods he closed his eyes and began to
cry that won't do you any good the crows
said I told you the answer is flying not
crying how hard can it be I'm doing it
the crow took to the air and flapped
around brains hand you have wings bran
pointed out maybe you do too bran felt
along his shoulders groping for feathers
there are different kinds of wings
the crows said bran was staring at his
arms his legs he was so skinny just skin
stretched torn over bones had he always
been so thin he tried to remember
a face swam up at him out of the gray
mist shining with light golden the
things I do for love it said Brian
screamed the crow took to the air
calling not that it shrieked at him
forget that you do not need it now put
it aside put it away
it landed on brain shoulder and pecked
at him and the shining golden face was
gone
bran was falling faster than ever the
gray mists howled around him as he
plunged toward the earth below what are
you doing to me
he asked the crow tearful teaching you
how to fly I can't fly you're flying
right now I'm falling every flight
begins with the fall the crow said
looked down I'm afraid looked down bran
looked down and he felt his insights
turned to water the ground was rushing
up at him now the whole world was spread
out below him a tapestry of white and
brown and green he could see everything
so clearly that for a moment he forgot
to be afraid he could see the whole
realm and everyone in it
he saw Winterfell as the Eagle see it
the tall towers looking squat and stubby
from above the castle walls just lines
in the dirt he saw maester Luwin on his
balcony studying the sky through a
polished bronze tube and frowning as he
made notes in a book he saw his brother
Rob taller and stronger than he
remembered him practicing swordplay in
the yard with real steel in his hand he
saw Hodor the simple giant from the
stables carrying an anvil to Macon's
Forge hefting onto a shoulder as easily
as another man might have to a bale of
hay at the heart of the godswood the
great white where wood burned it over
its reflection in the black pool its
leaves rustling in a chill wind when it
felt bran watching it lifted its eyes
from the still waters and stared back at
him knowingly he looked east and he saw
a galley racing across the waters of the
Bight he saw his mother sitting alone in
a cabin looking at a blood-stained knife
on a table in front of her as the rowers
pulled at their oars and Sir Roderick
leaned across the rail shaking and
heaving a storm was gathering ahead of
them
a vast dark roaring lashed by lightning
but somehow they could not see it
he looked south and he saw the great
blue-green rush on the Trident he saw
his father pleading with the King his
face etched with grief he saw songs of
crying herself to sleep at night and he
saw Aria watching in silence in holding
her secrets heart in her heart there
were shadows all around them one shadow
was dark as ash with the terrible face
of a hound another was armored like the
Sun golden and beautiful over them both
loomed a giant in Armour made of stone
but when he opened his visor there was
nothing inside but darkness and thick
black blood he lifted his eyes and saw
clear across the Narrow Sea to the Free
Cities in the green Dothraki sea and
beyond to vast earth wrack under its
mountain to the fabled lands of the Jade
sea to a shy by the shadow where dragons
stirred beneath the sunrise finally he
looked north
he saw the wall shining like blue
crystal and his bastard brother Jon
sleeping alone in a cold bed his skin
growing pale and hard as the memory of
all warmth fled from him and he looked
past the wall past endless forests
cloaked in snow past the frozen shore
and the great blue white rivers of ice
in the dead plains where nothing grew or
lived north and north and north he looks
to the curtain of light at the end of
the world and then beyond that curtain
he looked deep into the heart of winter
and then he cried out afraid in the heat
of his tears burned on his cheeks now
you know the crow whispered as if he
said on his shoulder now you know why
you must live why brain said not
understanding falling falling because
winter is coming bran looked at the crow
on his shoulder and the crow looked back
it had three eyes and the third eye was
full of terrible knowledge bran looked
down there was nothing below him now but
snow and cold and death and a frozen
wasteland were jagged blue-white spires
of ice waited to embrace him they flew
up at him like Spears he saw the bones
of a thousand other dreamers impaled
upon their points he was desperately
afraid can a man still be brave if he's
afraid he heard his own voice saying
small and far
a and his father's voice were applied to
him that is the only time a man can be
brave now bran the crow urged choose fly
or die death reached for him
screaming brain spread his arms and flew
wings unseen drink the wind and filled
and pulled him upward the terrible
needles of ice were seated below him the
sky opened up brain soared it was better
than climbing it was better than
anything the world grows small beneath
him I'm flying he cried out in delight
I've noticed said the three-eyed crow it
took to the air flapping its wings in
his face slowing him blinding him he
faltered in the air as its pinions beat
against his cheeks it's beak stabbed at
him fiercely and brain felt a sudden
blinding pain in the middle of his
forehead between his eyes what are you
doing he shrieked the crow opened its
beak and called at him a shrill scream
of fear and the gray mists shuddered and
swirled around him and ripped away like
a veil and he saw that the crow was
really a woman a serving woman with long
black hair and he knew her from
somewhere from Winterfell yes that was
it he remembered her now and then he
realized that he was in Winterfell in a
bed high in some chilly tower room and
the black haired woman dropped the basin
of water to shatter on the floor and ran
down the steps shouting he's awake he's
awake he's awake brain touched his
forehead between his eyes the place
where the crow had picked him was still
burning but there was nothing there no
blood no wound he felt weak and dizzy he
tried to get out of bed but nothing
happened and then there was movement
beside the bed and something landed
lightly on his legs he felt nothing a
pair of yellow eyes looked into his own
shining like the Sun the window was open
and it was cold in the room but the
warmth that came off the wolf and folded
him like a hot bath his pup brain
realized or was it he was so big now he
reached out to pet him he's saying
trembling like a leaf
when his brother robb burst into the
room breathless from his - up the tower
steps the direwolf was licking brain's
face brain looked up calmly his name is
summer he said all right now let's talk
about what happens during the chapter
as you can see the three-eyed crow
wasn't just trying to wake bran up but
he was also trying to open brains third
eye it isn't enough for brain to only
survive he needs to become a green seer
the three-eyed crow was telling bran
you must choose you either fly or die
but that's not as cut and dry as it may
seem at this point we all know the White
Walkers are coming and it seems like
they are a major threat to everyone's
existence if everything bran has been
told is true then he would be one of the
biggest factors in defeating the White
Walkers in order for brand to do this he
has to become a green seer and if he
doesn't become a green seer not only
would he die but so would everyone else
bran might not actually know this but he
has the weight of the entire realm
resting on his shoulders Bryan could
have been selfish and said you know what
I don't want to take this dangerous
journey out beyond the wall to find some
three-eyed crow in a cave he could have
said that if he wanted to but instead he
chose to fly and what he sees will
forever change him what I really like
about this so much is the fact that it's
happening so early in the very first
book depending on which copy you have
bran is able to see these things before
we're even 200 pages into the story
the first thing brain sees that has an
impact on him as related to his injury
this is a very important moment in
brains life because it led to him taking
this path he wanted to become a knight
but once he lost the use of his legs he
needed to find another purpose and
that's exactly what the three-eyed crow
intended on providing for him ever since
bran was pushed from the tower he has
struggled to remember who actually
pushed him the fact that he's in a coma
should tell you he did sustained a
significant head injury during this fall
so the memory of what happened that day
is a little cloudy
however bran does get a glimpse of Jaime
Lannister because it says he tried to
remember a face swam up at him out of
the gray mist shining with light golden
the things I do for love it said this
causes bran to scream because what
little memory he does have still
terrifies him we all know that was when
he was pushed because we remember what
Jaime said right beforehand and we all
know he can be associated with the word
golden
not only is his hair golden but his
king's guard armor is golden and later
on when he loses his hand it becomes
golden too now the reason why I wanted
to point this out is because of what the
crow said next when brain started to
scream the crow took to the air calling
not that it shrieked at him forget that
you do not need it now put it aside put
it away
I believe the crow is letting us know
brain and Jaime will meet again he told
brain you don't need to worry about that
now he did not tell him to forget about
it forever he simply said just put it
aside because I have more important
things to show you first you don't need
it now but you will need it later that's
what I'm thinking he's trying to say I
think most of us new brain and Jaime had
to meet again at some point but I think
bran will actually meet him in the
future
Jaime Lannister may play a big part in
the endgame and this is something brand
may come to find out later but let's
move on for now next brain starts to
learn how to fly and he's able to see
everything the whole world was spread
out below him a tapestry of white and
brown and green he could see everything
so clearly that for a moment he forgot
to be afraid he could see the whole
realm and everyone in it what brain
starts to see after this is all
basically happening in the present day
first he flies above his home Winterfell
and he sees your typical day-to-day
activities maester Luwin was looking at
the sky and making notes in his book
Robb was practicing with this sword in
the yard and Hodor was carrying an anvil
to make in sport this isn't very
interesting stuff bran would be able to
see all of this once he wakes up and
looks out his window but then he's able
to see things far and away when bran
looks east he can see a galley
racing across the waters of the Bight he
saw his mother sitting alone in a cabin
looking at a blood-stained knife on a
table in front of her as the rowers
pulled at oars and sir Roderick leaned
across a rail shaking and heaving a
storm was gathering ahead of them a vast
dark roaring lashed by lightning but
somehow they could not see it this is
shortly after the assassin tried to kill
bran the blood-stained knife Caitlin is
looking at is the cat's bald dagger
as brain is looking at this he doesn't
even realize his life was in danger a
second time because he's still in a coma
when the assassin came to his room even
though this has never said brain is
probably wondering why his mom is
holding that knife she is currently on a
way to see Ned to inform him about the
second attempt on brans life the
interesting thing about this passage is
the ominous storm that brain is able to
see this is foreshadowing the trouble
that lies ahead for his mother Catelyn
cannot see the storm because it's a
metaphor there's not an actual storm in
the sky above them but Catelyn has
embarked on a journey that will lead to
her death
she will never see brain again unless
she sees him as Lady Stoneheart bran
also saw his father pleading with the
king his face etched with grief he saw
Sansa crying herself to sleep at night
Annie saw arya watching in silence and
holding her secrets hard in her heart
this is when the rest of Brandt's family
is traveling down to King's Landing
Ned is pleading with the King because
he's trying to stop Songz's direwolf
lady from being killed this is why brain
is able to see Sansa crying herself to
sleep at night because of what happened
arya is watching in silence holding her
secrets heart in her heart she will
never forget what Joffrey and even
Cersei had done this ultimately leads to
Arya putting their names on her list
that moment accelerates arias character
into a much darker direction this
doesn't completely shatter Songz's hope
of becoming Joffrey's Queen but the
glass does start to crack and become a
spiderweb a web she will be trapped in
for quite some time
Bryan also notices there are shadows all
around them one Shadow was dark his ash
with the terrible face of a hound
another armored like the Sun golden and
beautiful over them both loomed a giant
and armor made of stone but when he
opened his visor there was nothing
inside but darkness and thick black
blood there are many different ways you
can interpret this but I think the first
shadow is obviously the Hound
he's dark as ash and ash can be in
relation to being burned and he has a
terrible face of a hound
if you read the books you will see the
hounds faces quite often referred to as
looking terrible and burnt the second
shadow sounds a lot like Jaime Lannister
it says he was armored like the Sun
golden and beautiful Jaime is often
described as being beautiful and golden
we also know Jaime and the Hound arrived
at Winterfell together so it would make
sense for them to still be together as
they head back down the Kings Road to
King's Landing it's the last shadow that
piques my interest the most this one
sounds like Gregor Clegane but the way
he is described sounds like brain is
glimpsing the future it says over them
both loomed a giant in armor made a
stone but when he opened his visor there
was nothing inside but darkness and
thick black blood as you can see he is
first described as a giant in armor made
of stone Gregor Clegane is a giant and
his armor being made of stone is a
reference to him being the mountain
because mountains are made of stone too
but when he opens his visor there's
nothing inside but darkness and thick
black blood this sounds a lot like the
mountain 2.0 but that doesn't happen
until he fights Oberyn Martel which is
much later in the story this would have
to mean brain is either seeing the
future or this is just for shadowing
what will eventually happened to Gregor
Clegane later in the book sky burn in
maester pycelle both make comments about
his veins turning black because of the
poison in his blood in the books it's
also rumoured that Gregor Clegane no
longer has a head so maybe this is why
there is nothing behind the man's visor
but darkness and thick black blood the
black blood could also be a reference to
him being reanimated there are other
characters that have been brought back
from the dead and their blood always
seems to be black after this happens
Melisandre's blood is black as well
which makes me think Melisandre was also
resurrected by real or but already made
a video about that anyways the shadows
brand sees all around his family sound
like the Hound
Jaime Lannister and the mountain that's
the way I always saw it but if you think
it's someone else feel free to leave
your thoughts down below what brain sees
next is pretty interesting it says he
lifted his eyes and saw clear across the
Narrow Sea to the Free Cities and the
green Dothraki
and beyond device Toth rack under its
mountain to the fabled lands of the Jade
Sea to a shy by the shadow where dragons
stirred beneath the sunrise everything
bran is being shown seems to be in the
present day or near future this always
made me wonder if there could be more
dragons in the realm we know Illyrio
gave Danny the dragon eggs and he told
her they were from a shy but when bran
is looking at a shy and seeing dragons
star beneath the sunrise Danny already
has her dragon eggs with her so what is
brand actually looking at could this
just be a reference to Danny's dragons
or is he seeing something else
Danny was given her eggs during her
wedding that was a few chapters before
this one so I'm thinking there could be
more dragons or more dragon eggs in his
shy
I think if bran was looking at Danny's
dragons it should say they were stirring
in Pentos where the Haig's are currently
at but this makes it sound like
something else is waking up in his shy
by the shadow but that's just my opinion
let's move on to the next one it says
finally he looked north
he saw the wall shining like blue
crystal and his bastard brother John
sleeping alone in a cold bed his skin
growing pale and hard as the memory of
warmth fled from him at first glance
this might not seem like anything
noteworthy but some people believe this
could be an image of John after he was
stabbed by his brothers of the Nights
Watch it says John is sleeping alone
which is kind of weird because John
always sleeps with ghosts
it does say his skin is growing pale and
hard almost like a dead person's body
would grow stiff but you have to
remember John is in the far north where
it's extremely cold I'm not sure if I
want to believe bran is looking at John
as he's about to die but I would like to
believe bran is being shown all these
things for a reason there should be some
significance to each one but I want to
move on to the last sighting I think
this one shows why the Starks originally
chose their house words winter is coming
the last one says he looked past the
wall pass to the endless forest cloaked
in snow past the frozen shore in the
great blue-white rivers of ice and the
dead plains where nothing grew or lay
north and north and north he looked to
the curtain of light at the end of the
world and then beyond that curtain he
looked deep into the heart of winter and
then he cried out afraid in the heat of
his tears burned on his cheeks now you
know the crow whispered as it said on
his shoulder now you know why you must
live why brain said not understanding
falling falling because winter is coming
brain looked at the crow on his shoulder
and the crow looked back it had three
eyes and the third eye was full of a
terrible knowledge brain looked down
there was nothing below him now but snow
and coat in death a frozen wasteland
were jagged blue-white spires of ice
waited to embrace him they flew up at
him like Spears he saw the bones of a
thousand other dreamers and paled upon
their points he was desperately afraid
that is the main reason why I have
always said the stark words meant
something much deeper than just winter
is coming the Starks have forgotten the
true meaning of this phrase over time
but the three-eyed crow is showing bran
what it truly means that's why he says
those words when bran is looking into
the heart of winter where the others
reside
that's why brand must live this is why
he must fly
what bran had seen terrified him causing
him to cry out in fear you see the
storks have a deep-rooted history what
the others and I think that was either
forgotten over time or it was kept a
secret of her time but bran stark will
start to unravel this mystery as he
begins to train with blood Raven in his
cave winter is coming is not just a
reminder that summer is coming to an end
the founders of House Stark would say
this as a warning because life as they
knew it could possibly be coming to an
end but that was forgotten in fact in
the present day most of the characters
don't even believe the White Walkers
were ever real but as bran stark looks
down into the heart of winter he can see
a thousand other green seers impaled
upon these magical ice Spears that were
created by the others but Bryan is
quickly learning that he may be the one
true Green
that can save the entire realm all he
needs to do is fly
[Music]
[Music]
you